In July we usually go down to San Diego
for a week of shows at Comic-Con.
Obviously, this year
Comic-Con did not happen
because of COVID.
However, that did not
stop our friends at Funko,
the company that makes Pop! vinyl figures,
from once again creating
five new limited edition
Conan Pop! figures.
Yes, five. Check 'em out.
There is yours truly as
Wonder Woman right there.
Got the lasso and everything.
You've got...
Oh, this is cool.
Conan as Chucky,
which sadly just looks like me.
Yeah.
No real difference.
Mini-Conan.
Yeah.
Here's
Conan as Marty McFly.
Yes. That's a good one.
You gotta have that one.
Here's
Conan as Aquaman.
I'm fierce in this one. I've
got a trident and everything.
Yeah. Look out, he'll swim at ya.
(Conan laughs)
And then look at this sexy pose.
Conan as Dr. Ian Malcolm.
Look at that.
That is a sensual doll.
Oh, is that like the Jeff Goldblum thing?
Yeah, Jeff Goldblum.
"Jurassic Park."
He's gonna be pissed.
Look at that. And guess what?
This is now the second-most
sensual doll I own.
Oh boy.
Okay, these are collectible vinyl figures
that we normally give out at Comic-Con.
Instead we're giving
them away to our viewers
over the next two weeks.
A special code will be shown
each night during "Conan."
To enter, go to TBS.com/conanpop,
enter that night's code, see
if you're an instant winner.
Fans also have a second chance to win
by following Team Coco on
Instagram, Facebook and Twitter.
Gang, you gotta get these.
Think of it: someday your family
is gonna have to remove these
from your house after you die
and find some use for them.
It's exciting.